[Música]
saben ustedes que tienen en común estos
países
singapur
tailandia
china
taiwán japón
korea
filipinas
emiratos árabes unidos-
malasia
indonesia
rusia
qatar
india
y costa rica todos ellos han sido sede y
anfitriones de la olimpiada mundial de
robótica sí tal vez muchos de ustedes no
lo sabían pero nuestro país fue la
capital de la robótica en el año 2017
más de 65 países de diferentes
continentes más de 3.000 participantes
entre niños y jóvenes de diferentes
países de diferentes partes del mundo se
dieron cita aquí en costa rica y se
dieron cita para trabajar en torno al
tema de la robótica todos resolvieron
problemas y retos donde estábamos
ayudando al planeta en la sostenibilidad
y eso ocurrió aquí en costa rica
en costa rica sí y por qué porque
escogieron a un país como costa rica
pues bueno en costa rica tenemos muchas
capacidades y hemos desarrollado mucho
el tema de la robótica educativa desde
hace más de 20 años nuestros niños
nuestros jóvenes trabajan en temas
relacionados con la construcción la
programación y el control de robots
el 2017 fue un año de primeras veces
para nuestro país por primera vez en el
2017 la olimpiada mundial de robótica
salió de asia y no se fue a cualquier
otro país ni a cualquier otro continente
se vino a américa y se vino a costa rica
que somos una parte pequeñita en el
centro del continente además por primera
vez una mujer organizó y estuvo
liderando un evento de esta magnitud
mundial
varios factores intervinieron para que
nuestro país estuviera en este panel
mundial primero nuestros gobiernos han
apostado y han invertido en la ciencia
en la tecnología en la educación de
niños y jóvenes para formar parte de
este tipo de proyectos
nuestros niños nuestros jóvenes están
capacitando cada día más en temas
relacionados con ciencia tecnología y
particularmente con el tema de la
robótica además de esto nuestro país es
referencia a nivel de la región
latinoamericana porque hemos tenido muy
buen desempeño en los eventos de
robótica a nivel mundial
y otra primera vez nuestro país además
de ser sede va a ser también
representante en el consejo mundial de
la olimpiada de robótica
qué implicaba para nosotros que
implicaba para costa rica ser el
organizador de un evento de calibre
mundial por supuesto implicaba mucho
trabajo implicaba estar en los ojos del
mundo durante todo un año
implicaba que nos tocaba liderar el
proceso de robótica a nivel mundial pero
eso también representó que un equipo de
jóvenes ingenieros ticos fuimos los que
desarrollamos y los que lideramos los
retos que se resolvieron en todo el
mundo durante todo el año en torno al
tema de robots para la sostenibilidad
en este momento ya llevamos algunos
minutos y he mencionado en varias
ocasiones la palabra robótica
pero que es robótica o que se imaginan
ustedes cuando escuchan que alguien les
habla de robótica o de robots
posiblemente y de forma inevitable
pensamos en el hombre bicentenario
en arturito y por supuesto en walt y no
podía faltar
pero si buscamos en un diccionario la
definición de robótica vamos a encontrar
una definición seria que dice lo
siguiente la robótica es la ciencia o
rama de la tecnología que estudia el
diseño y construcción de máquinas
capaces de desempeñar tareas realizadas
por el ser humano o que requieren del
uso de inteligencia
pongamos atención a esto cuál es el
objetivo de la robótica cuál es el
objetivo de los robots dicen qué
queremos robots que sean capaces de
desempeñar tareas realizadas por el ser
humano eso quiere decir que la robótica
es una ciencia en la que trabajamos para
desarrollar robots que ayuden al ser
humano
una refrigeradora una licuadora una
aspiradora son elementos de uso
cotidiano de ustedes y míos que nos
ayudan nos ayudan mucho en nuestras
labores diarias pero serán robots
básicamente para que un artefacto o una
máquina se considere un robot debe tener
la capacidad de darse cuenta de lo que
está pasando en su entorno debe tener la
capacidad de sentir por medio de
sensores y poder identificar los
diferentes elementos presentes en su
ambiente
si los robots existen para ayudar al ser
humano entonces en qué áreas queremos
que los robots nos ayuden o cuáles
tareas queremos que los robots hagan por
nosotros y cuando pensamos de esa forma
es cuando a veces ya no nos parece tan
bonita la cosa
si ustedes tienen un automóvil
posiblemente la mayor parte de ese
vehículo fue fabricado por medio de
robots
de igual manera sus televisores sus
teléfonos celulares sus computadoras y
en general muchos de los elementos que
utilizamos que provienen de la industria
del plástico han sido fabricados por el
robots en nuestra vida cotidiana
encontramos muchos elementos que han
sido fabricados por medio de robots
lo que antes parecía de ciencia ficción
ahora es una realidad esto es una
realidad
ya no es ciencia ficción ver una
intervención quirúrgica realizada
únicamente por robots sin la
intervención de un médico cirujano
entonces si esto es una realidad las
cifras así lo demuestran actualmente la
federación internacional de robótica
dice que tenemos un 1.63 millones de
robots industriales presentes presentes
en diferentes líneas de producción en
diferentes áreas
si vemos el mapa mundial nos damos
cuenta que los países que tienen mayor
inserción de robots en sus líneas de
producción son
singapur corea del sur y alemania
si analizamos latinoamérica los países
de nuestra región que tienen mayor
presencia y mayor inserción de robots en
las líneas de producción son mexico
argentina y brasil
en este caso no estamos hablando
precisamente de robots que tienen forma
humana como terminator o como el hombre
bicentenario sino robots que por medio
de brazos herramientas diferentes
utensilios realizan labores
de manera más precisa y en menor tiempo
que los seres humanos entonces si
queremos que los robots nos ayuden
porque a veces nos da como miedo será
que van a desplazar al ser humano será
que nos van a desplazar los hicimos para
que nos ayuden será que nos van a
eliminar cuando en el 2016 foxconn la
compañía china que diseña dispositivos
electrónicos para apple y samsung
anunció que iba a eliminar 60.000
puestos de trabajo porque los iba a
sustituir por el robots y por máquinas
inteligentes
los mayores temores
a nivel industrial y de los sindicatos
ya se podrán imaginar también
florecieron por supuesto
y vamos a ser sustituidos por las
máquinas es como el cuento del coco nos
hasta nos asustan todos hemos escuchado
temores de ese tipo
los robots van a sustituir al ser humano
en un futuro no muy lejano
si vemos algunos datos del foro mundial
nos dicen que para el 2020
5 millones de puestos de trabajo dentro
de las 15 economías más desarrolladas
del planeta van a ser sustituidos por el
robots a 5 millones de empleos 5
millones de seres humanos se van a
quedar sin empleo porque van a ser
sustituidos por robots
y por otro lado
otros datos y otras estadísticas nos
muestran que con la cantidad de robots
que tenemos instalados actualmente en
nuestras industrias esto ha permitido la
creación de 8 millones de empleos y en
los próximos años vamos a tener un
millón de empleos más generados a raíz
de la presencia de estos robots en las
líneas industriales
qué quiere decir esto esto quiere decir
que la presencia de la robótica en la
industria nos está permitiendo generar
empleos más calificados la robótica los
robots no nos están desplazando
simplemente nos están ayudando a cambiar
están migrando la forma como trabajamos
o los lugares las áreas donde trabajamos
ahora estamos hablando de empleos más
calificados empleos ya no en líneas de
producción sino empleos en la parte
técnica quienes van a reparar quienes
van a construir quienes van a controlar
estas líneas robotizadas o estas líneas
automatizadas
donde encontramos esta cantidad enorme
de robots principalmente los podemos
encontrar en industrias por ejemplo como
la automotriz que es la industria con
mayor penetración de robots a nivel
mundial es de las industrias que más
apuesta por las líneas automatizadas y
por las líneas inteligentes de igual
manera en la actualidad encontramos
muchos robots que trabajan en el área de
los servicios mejorando procesos que
además son repetitivos y monótonos para
el ser humano y los robots están
llegando a colaborar con nosotros en
estos procesos
vamos a ver algunos números
dónde están estos robots
en este gráfico podemos observar el 'top
ten' de los países que tienen mayor
presencia de robots en sus industrias
los expertos concuerdan que la mejor
manera de medirlo es midiendo la
cantidad de robots presentes en la
industria por cada 10.000 empleados
activos entonces aquí podemos ver como
países corea del sur singapur alemania
japón suecia ocupan los cinco primeros
lugares por ejemplo corea del sur que es
el primero tiene una penetración de 631
robots por cada 10.000 empleados activos
ahí siguen en esa lista
dinamarca eeuu italia bélgica taiwán
los países latinoamericanos estamos muy
por debajo del promedio
el promedio como lo pueden ver ahí es de
74 robots por cada 10.000 empleados
activos y en latinoamérica el país que
ocupa el primer lugar en nuestra región
en méxico y apenas tiene 30 robots por
cada 10.000 empleados a nivel industrial
le sigue argentina y de último brasil y
costa rica que creen que pasa con
nuestro país nuestro país ni siquiera
aparece en esa lista
entonces queremos una costa rica-
robotizada será que eso es lo que
nosotros queremos o será que estamos
preparados
en nuestro país hemos hecho las cosas
bien hemos empezado desde el principio
hemos empezado por las bases hemos
formado a los niños a las niñas a los
jóvenes en el área de la robótica cuando
le preguntamos a unos niños y jóvenes en
la olimpiada nacional de robótica que
quieren estudiar cuando sean grande esto
respondieron mecatrónica ingeniería en
computación electrónica
yo quiero ser ingeniero yo quiero ser
ingeniera
qué creen ustedes que va a ocurrir
cuando estos niños están niñas lleguen
al sector productivo de nuestro país
por supuesto vamos a tener ingenieros
que han sido formados desde sus orígenes
en el área de la robótica vamos a tener
mejoras en nuestro sistema productivo
vamos a tener sistemas productivos
especializados robotizados ya nosotros
estamos preparados para el siguiente
paso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]